before you could see a setting at the
base camp a place in the middle of the
land with all our infrastructure like
water and electricity it covers our
basic needs it's a good short-term base
to work from so we could focus our time
on exploring the land
now after almost two years of observing
we are finally going to start long-term
planning
first step is making maps welcome to new
project camp update
all right so up until now we spend most
of our time here on base camp and not
really on the other parts of the land
because we first wanted to see where we
actually are before we do any drastic
changes so talking with the neighbors
observing the trees the climate
and we've been doing that now for a
while and it's time to really put all
this data together so for instance we
have data from
satellite maps online tools to create
contour lines mark flew a drone to
create a height map of the land
we had many chats with the neighbors
about the history of the land we walked
around a lot ourselves to just observe
the good and the bad things highway
sounds naomi mapped out all the native
trees on the land we looked at websites
about the climate to see the previous
years about the wind the direction the
humidity the temperatures and we cleaned
up and measured all the structures on
the land the ruins we have to see what
is already there so at this point we
have a lot of information on our hats on
papers conversations so now it's time to
put it all together so we kind of create
a few maps which contain all this
information we gathered so it's easier
to share to talk about
but before we can make the final data
sheet we have one thing to do because in
update 33 we discovered a small new
little ruin which we didn't know existed
so
here we have the ruin
and this one isn't really modern like
the other ruins we found it's just big
granite stones
which keep it nice and cool and we're
not really sure what we'd use it for yet
but it's nice to find it because it's
really easy to legalize these structures
and then we can build here whatever we
want in the future
and we never cleaned it up so before
we're going to have the final data we
first need to make sure we clean that
ruin measure it
and then we can make our maps so time to
clean up oh yeah and just for your
reference the rune is located right here
in the middle of all these bushes it's
very dense a lot of things to chop so
get started
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello emma
hey how you doing
doing fine just
deciding
where to start the new path
because from this whole path we need to
reach the
the ruin
that is over there
hi julie
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after some artwork we cleared up the
ruin and now is accessible so that we
can have a better look at it
so this is the result of artwork
yeah or maybe of stupidity
what's the name of the cringe like no
the
piece of metal that can
turn the door i don't know his back uh
place is really squared
and
really stretched and uh i feel like it
was something
as a mandatory
a place where
farmers can feed the animals
this looks like a structural point yeah
we think also that in these huge rocks
they
they make this place for uh putting a
structural beam
maybe a
big huge
wooden beam
coming from that side
and
to support all the roof for the
the roof yeah back to basecamp we took
some measurement of the ruin made a
survey of it
and with this drawing i
did a
digital model
and some
[Music]
digital maps
we are trying to legalize the buildings
on site on the on the property and
we need all the
infos about the that
so i will show you some of these maps
this is the floor plan
i translated the survey into uh this
really simple digital drawing and you
can see from the top that is 17 square
meter only some walls are still standing
up and from the side the maximum height
that we have
measured is 1.4 meter let me show you
how it's placed on the land with some
maps
so here is the
the property and we have some ruins of
building on it coming from open street
maps we don't know yet who plays it but
it was nice to see maps already updated
we have some contour lines here is base
cam
and
trying to add also the ruins on it
in the meantime we also made a map it's
a 3d model it's made thanks to
photos taken by the drone and trying to
also add some model of the ruins and all
the data that we already have available
on it
and it's a nice way to
browse through the land
and to see for example base camp here
and finally we have some auto photos
made by the satellites it's won
roughly each year since 2006
all the way up to right now
and i will show you some details some
interesting stuff that i found on it
[Music]
2006 we can see that the land was in use
dashed line is the property
the land was in use the ruins were used
and the grass around it was scattered
2010
behind the ruin it's like a little path
that now is completely hided by the
mimosas
and we can see some movement in the
neighbor's land they usually
raised all the land to the ground to
plant eucalyptus trees
2011
is a interesting story about this big
[ __ ] tree
we can see from this map that is still
alive while other also trees are green
but if we go to the next one that is
2013
the big cork tree looks like it's
already dying it's grayish and all the
other trees are still green
what we think is that
the neighbors
doing like a temporary road in some way
cutted some rules or made some changes
and the big cork didn't survive
in the meantime municipality cutted
grass under the
electric lines through the land where
they cut is like really going to the
ground and in the top side of the land
border we can see the eucalyptus farm
growing
new plot of land completely turned down
and
planted
2015
the big cork unfortunately is dead
and
yeah still the eucalyptus farm growing
2007
it seems like every three years the
municipality
cleaned electric lines
and the neighbors also
completely cleared this area
to make maybe some other plantation
2018 is an interesting map it's the
first image that we have after the
wildfire of 2017 october it was a huge
wildfire almost 80 percent of all the
forestry in this municipality was
completely burned and five people died
from it in our land all of it was
completely turned down
almost all of the
trees gone
2019 almost three years after the fires
all the
trees are growing back and
also neighbors are planting more
eucalyptus
2021 we have some
vans in the land base camp is growing
and few containers coming from the
netherlands
and finally this is 2020
it's august is the last map we have and
we made it with the drone shots i will
go through some details
we can see clearly base camp is changing
some place for the vans a place for
tents
here the two main ruins
the fields on the front of the land and
we can see here the ruin that we cleared
finally we have all the data and images
gathered from public databases
satellites drone mapping and surveys of
the property and its buildings
now we can make some helpful maps
first of all this is a basic conversion
of the
model coming from the drone map
into a colorful mop the red areas are
the highest and we are talking about 344
meters above sea level and the lowest
point in the land is
280 meters
base gum is a 304 meters here
having in mind the environment and the
climate we made some graphic maps here
we highlighted the summer wind coming
from the north
the frost in the morning coming from
south
and the differences between winter sun
and summer sun more in detail we have
here the solar disc is basically show
each day of the year where the position
of the sun is is based on this location
and it's useful to
just predict the
sun position and his angle to build the
construction to build windows for
example
in the scheme we highlighted some
challenges mainly wildfires coming from
the woods behind us and the highway
noise coming from the west
this map is still in progress we are
highlighting all the trees locked by
naomi
and all the native species and we can
see some trends for example that
here we have a lot of mimosas and the
place where there's not any mimosas
other species can grow
we also made them up with all the water
lines the creek
we can see here the pond
the water reserve behind the
base camp the well and finally we made a
planimetry with all this kind of
information placed
coming from the bottom we can see the
creek the big room small ruin
and following the street we arrive at
the base camp
we
advance with tents
in the corner
behind the base count we can see yoga
deck
near the water reserve
uh well on the other side of the street
we go on the top of the hill where
there's another yoga deck and going on
the side
we will reach the waterfall and the
lagoon this is the work that we did so
far
we are trying to keep the maps update
updated and we will upload all this work
on the website in the research module if
you have any feedback any question let
us know there
so here we are on top of the land
instead of using satellite data and
drones we can also just climb up and
have a look
uh which is quite nice to get a bit of
an overview
yeah the main reason for making all
these maps and this data is that it's
easier for us internally to have all the
data in one place so we can start
planning but also to share it with other
people like you guys and maybe people
that want to help out landscaping or
looking into how do we grow our forest
how do we divide our zones so we're
going to share all of those maps in the
research module and continue the
planning from there
and the main thing we're actually
looking into is on the one hand that's
what is a bit of a complex puzzle
because on the one hand we want to make
sure that ecologically it makes sense
what we're doing so we take the right
trees and put the water retention in the
right areas
but then you also have just legally what
is allowed to do there's certain
limitations depending on if it's
florestrol area or urban area so we have
to work with that
and then also we just have personal
wishes so for instance we might like
certain areas of the land more than
others depending on the sound or the sun
so those three layers we sort of need to
paste on top of each other to really
make up a final plan a master plan for
this land
but we're going to continue to work on
that first thing we did is we also
printed out one of those maps so we can
just stare at it and uh yeah think in
our minds
but yeah all of this work will continue
in the research module so if you want to
follow it make sure to click the link
below or just keep watching these videos
and i'm sure we'll talk about it again
in the future for now that was it for
this video if you want to want to see
the next video make sure to support on
patreon so you can see it one week ahead
of everyone else
or not then we'll just see you again
here next week same channel same time
thanks for watching
you